so all the comedying bros they they're
all universal in their hatred for joe
manchin see you know that you are in
line with the common man when the folks
at the top of the comedy hierarchy your
late night host who in millions of
dollars are very angry at joe manchin
the senator from west virginia is why
listening to david brooks who once
suggested that he likes barack obama
because of the way he pleaded his pants
i'm not kidding you that's the thing
david brooks actually said back in 2008
david brooks who is like the yuppie of
all guppies listening to david brooks
about the morality of spending this much
money while ripping on
joe manchin is just it's peak democratic
elitism
so here you have the daily show ripping
joe manchin
introducing
politics game where everyone works
together
almost
we're gonna pass an infrastructure bill
you play is the democratic majority in
the senate but watch out one player is
the mansion i have concerns over the
partisan nature of this legislation uh
oh
looks like someone's the mansion but
kyle we're all on the same team you know
america this bill cannot move forward
without the support of at least one
republican colleague
but there are no republicans here they
didn't want to play
with mansion you can feel the excitement
of a narrow majority held hostage by one
sanctimonious dead
so much humor one's he's a sanctimoni
you see uh-huh
it's funny it's funny man
really pushing the boundaries of comedy
remember that time when comedy used to
make you laugh uh seth myers doesn't
here's seth meyers being not funny
you've got two senators joe manchin
who's been called a king maker by fossil
fuel executives and personally profits
from the coal industry and kirsten
cinema who's raked in hundreds of
thousands in donations from big pharma
has been raising money from business
groups holding up a bill that would
tackle climate change establish paid
family leave make community college
tuition free transform child care and
expand access to health care among many
other things name one thing in this bill
you think is unpopular paid family leave
child care tax credit dental benefits
for medicare
he's so funny he's so i i am enjoying
the notion from democrats that if you
don't vote the way that they want you to
vote it's because you're being bribed
the joe manchin is doing this because of
the bribery and so is christian cinema
that's why because they're being bribed
that's that's clearly the issue here um
so a few things one if we're going to
talk about open bribery the democratic
party is so inhoc to places like the
teachers unions that they will literally
rewrite cdc standards in order to please
the teachers unions second of all as a
typical rule you take donations from
groups that are politically aligned with
you
okay and if chris and cinema were
presumably aligned the other way should
be receiving
donations from other groups i mean
that's how politics typically works but
really good on you guys good on the
elite media for deciding that anyone who
disagrees with them it's because they're
attempting bribery all the while
ignoring the fact that the entire
democratic program is an attempt to
bribe voters with their own money they
take money from in some cases not their
own money in some cases from their
next-door neighbor right their name
we'll take your name next-door
neighbor's money we'll give it to you
and then and then you'll vote for us
seems to be the democratic pitcher
but they're all for the common man it's
all the common man it's all the common
good again their their basic idea here
is we spend endless amounts of money
forever and there's no downside ever and
all we gain is more and more control
over your life
now i would be remiss if i did not note
that there is a
new standard with regard to immigration
i mean this administration is a bleep
show in so many ways the dhs has issued
new arrests and deportation guidelines
to immigration agents right this comes
just a week after the dhs lied about its
own agents by suggesting they were
whipping immigrants illegal immigrants
at the border the biden administration
said that biden said it hara said it
majorcase said it it was all a lie now
the dhs is issuing new regulations what
do these regulations do according to the
washington post quote
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas issued broad new directives to
immigration officers on thursday saying
the fact that someone is an undocumented
immigrant quote should not alone be the
basis of a decision to detain and deport
them from the united states
oh that's not
but
aren't you like the immigration
like border patrol so your job is to
patrol the border but if someone crosses
the border illegally
that is not alone the basis to detain or
deport them from the united states
hmm
i wonder why people think there's an
open border here it's it's bewildering
to me who could have predicted such a
thing
the same time these people are releasing
there are 15 000 people under the bridge
in del rio texas 10 to 12 000 of them
according to marcus entered the united
states i wonder why everyone thinks
there's an open border here in the
united states maybe because there's an
open border here in the united states
thanks to these tool bags so now you're
not just combining bad economic policy
with inflationary policy and bad fiscal
policy you got bad economic policy bad
fiscal policy endless welfare benefits
in an open border i can't see how
anything here is gonna is gonna be bad
it's all probably gonna be great
even bernie sanders used to be in favor
of a closed border he was in favor of a
close border because he made the
perfectly plausible and rational
argument that if you offer endless
welfare benefits to people and leave the
border open you won't be able to pay for
everyone so much for that we've got an
administration that wants endless
welfare benefits for pretty much
everybody
and also an open border
an amnesty program is on the way for
those who say well you know illegal
immigrants can't receive things like
federal welfare benefits first of all
they can receive in some states state
welfare benefits they receive free
public education for their kids but
beyond that
the administration would very much like
to make all these people citizens as
fast as humanly possible
does this look like a recipe for the
success of the united states or does it
look like an attempt to gain ultimate
power for the rest of time by the
democratic party endless welfare
benefits endless bribery endless
spending combined with open borders is
one hell of a combo
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science
[Music]